COMMITTEE RELEASED THAT NEW CLIP
FROM ITS NEXT HEARING, I SPOKE
WITH A KEY MEMBER OF THE PANEL.
JOINING US NOW, A KEY MEMBER OF
THE JANUARY 6 HOUSE SELECT
COMMITTEE, DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSWOMAN ZOE LOFGREN.
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
I WANT TO REMIND OUR VIEWERS
WHAT YOU TOLD CNN YESTERDAY
ABOUT THE TRUMP FAMILY PROFITING
OFF THESE ELECTION LIES.
WATCH THIS.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> YOU WERE JUST ASKED, I THINK,
BY MANU RAJU IF THE COMMITTEE
HAS FOUND EVIDENCE THAT TRUMP
AND HIS FAMILY, QUOTE,
PERSONALLY BENEFITED FROM
DONATIONS, AND YOU SAID YES.
THAT'S A SERIOUS ALLEGATION.
DO YOU HAVE MORE DETAILS?
IS THAT A CRIME?
>> I DON'T KNOW -- YOU KNOW,
WE'RE A LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE SO
THAT'S FOR SOMEBODY ELSE TO
DECIDE.
BUT, FOR EXAMPLE, WE KNOW THAT
GUILFOYLE WAS PAID FOR THE
INTRODUCTION SHE GAVE AT THE
SPEECH ON JANUARY 6th.
SHE RECEIVED COMPENSATION FOR
THAT.
>> BUT IS THAT A CRIME?
>> I'M NOT SAYING IT'S A CRIME,
BUT I THINK IT'S A GRIFT.
>> CNN HAS SINCE LEARNED,
CONGRESSWOMAN, IT WAS TURNING
POINT USA, A SEPARATE
CONSERVATIVE PRO TRUMP
ORGANIZATION THAT ACTUALLY PAID
KIMBERLY GUILFOYLE.
DID YOU MISCHARACTERIZE THAT
PAYMENT?
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
IT'S ONE -- IT'S PART AND PARCEL
OF THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, THE MAJOR
DONOR TO THAT WAS A WOMAN WHO
TOOK THE FIFTH AMENDMENT WHEN
SHE WAS INTERVIEWED BY US, WHO
SPECIFICALLY EXCLUDED SPEAKERS'
FEES FROM HER DONATION.
AND OBVIOUSLY THAT WAS DONE IN
CONTRAVENTION TO THAT CAVEAT.
BUT THE QUESTION IS ARE TRUMP
INDIVIDUALS BENEFITTING FROM
THIS WHOLE ENTERPRISE OF RAISING
MONEY AROUND THE SO-CALLED STOP
THE STEAL, AND THE ANSWER IS
YES.
YOU KNOW, WE WILL -- I'M WORKING
WITH THE COMMITTEE STAFF, THE
ACCOUNTANTS AND FINANCIAL
LAWYERS.
WE'RE GOING TO PUT OUT SOME
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION AND
PEOPLE CAN LOOK AT WHAT WE HAVE
AND REACH THEIR OWN CONCLUSIONS.
WE HOPE TO HAVE THAT OUT IN THE
NEXT COUPLE OF DAYS.
>> WE'LL LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
ALL THAT INFORMATION.
YOUR COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN, BENNIE
THOMPSON, SAID LAST NIGHT THAT
THE COMMITTEE WILL NOT MAKE ANY
CRIMINAL REFERRALS TO THE U.S.
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
DID HE SPEAK TOO SOON IN RULING
THAT OUT?
>> WELL, IN TALKING TO BENNIE, I
THINK HE -- I DON'T WANT TO
SPEAK FOR HIM, BUT I THINK HIS
COMMENT WAS MISCONSTRUED, I
THINK.
REALLY -- HERE'S THE FACT.
THE COMMITTEE HAS NOT YET HAD A
DISCUSSION ABOUT ANYTHING
RELATIVE TO CRIMINAL REFERRALS.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, THERE ARE
NO SUCH THINGS AS CRIMINAL
REFERRALS.
THERE'S NO LIKE PROCESS IN
STATUTE.
WE HAVEN'T HAD A DISCUSSION
ABOUT WHETHER WE'LL SEND A
LETTER TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE OR NOT, BECAUSE THAT
BASICALLY IS WHAT THE DISCUSSION
IS ABOUT, BUT IT'S PREMATURE.
WE'RE CERTAINLY GOING TO FINISH
OUR HEARINGS BEFORE WE HAVE THAT
DISCUSSION.
I PERSONALLY BELIEVE THAT IN THE
END, WE WILL END UP SENDING ALL
OF THE INFORMATION THAT WE HAVE
TO THE PUBLIC AND TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, ALL THE
EVIDENCE, WHICH IS REALLY THE
MAIN POINT.
NOW, THE COMMITTEE HAS VIEWS,
EACH ONE OF US DOES.
AMERICAN CITIZENS HAVE VIEWS
ABOUT WHAT THEY HAVE SEEN.
BUT IN THE END, ONLY THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE CAN DECIDE
WHETHER OR NOT TO PROSECUTE.
>> THEY CAN PROSECUTE WITH OR
WITHOUT FORMAL CRIMINAL
REFERRALS FROM YOUR COMMITTEE.
ON ANOTHER SENSITIVE ISSUE --
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> -- D.C. CAPITOL POLICE SAY
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE THAT
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN BARRY
LOUDERMILK LED A RECONNAISSANCE
TOUR WITH TRUMP SUPPORTERS JUST
AHEAD OF THE JANUARY 6
INSURRECTION.
WHAT'S YOUR REACTION TO THAT?
>> WELL, I WAS QUITE SURPRISED
BY THAT.
I'LL TELL YOU, WE WILL HAVE SOME
INFORMATION, THE COMMITTEE WILL
BE RELEASING SOME INFORMATION ON
THAT POINT, YOU KNOW, VERY SOON,
MAYBE LATER TODAY OR TOMORROW.
>> SO DO YOU BELIEVE HE DID LEAD
SOME SORT OF RECONNAISSANCE TOUR
FOR POTENTIAL RIOTERS THE DAY
BEFORE?
>> WE HAVE VIDEO EVIDENCE THAT
CAUSED US TO SEND A LETTER.
WE DIDN'T MAKE ANY ACCUSATIONS.
WE SAID WE WANTED TO ASK HIM
SOME QUESTIONS AND HE'S REFUSED
TO TALK TO THE COMMITTEE.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY.
AND WHEN YOU SEE THE PICTURES
THAT WE WILL RELEASE,